[Music]
while this logo shoots meteors into the
air I've got to ask since we're on the
fifth Transformers movie has anyone
figured out why these movies need to be
150 minutes long the dark ages that's
pretty vague if you care about history
at all no one knows who's fighting who
or why you should care and this battle
scene comes with all the clarity and
sensitivity you'd expect from the guy
who made pain and gain and a few other
movies I'm forgetting it's almost like
the studio said man that guy ritchie
king arthur movie is gonna do
gangbusters let's feed off the
inevitable wave a popularity by making
our movie tie-in somehow look this movie
is only two minutes in and even I'm
willing to admit I'm hoping this asshole
was talking about the end of the movie
five full seconds of this guy drinking
he had this last little nip of alcohol
and then did all this writing magic does
exist three minutes into the picture
Anthony Hopkins starts narrating about
magic I'm not sure whether this movie is
Thor now you see me there are theory in
tales or no apart too but you could have
started here and speared me the terrible
battle scenes this movie opened well
Merlin's been on screen for less than 30
seconds but it's already exceeded the
entire alcohol intake of Valkyrie and
Thor Ragnarok it's awful I mean you
should see the editing in the camera
angles honestly a three-headed
transformer dragon we're really doing
this transformers are declared illegal
on earth world to set up a new
paramilitary force exposition dump is
dump Captain Cuba Castro lets them son
on his beaches yeah but why does this
bring in tourism dollars and do these
huge complex machines really enjoy the
heat
mojito needs ice god damn it robots
discount Stand By Me movie saves money
by reusing the footage from Bane's
attack and the Dark Knight Rises hey man
your shirt says basketball is my
girlfriend I want you to step back and
understand the optics of what you just
did none of these idiot kids breaks a
bone during this bone breaking tumble
Isabella winds up to throw these bottles
which the security guard robots eagerly
shoot out after she throws them but why
didn't they take a shot at her winding
up to throw these bottles in the first
place do they know she's one of the
protagonists armed and hostile I got
kids in danger fire we really need to
protect those kids now fire your missile
the giant transformer that's just two
feet away from them jeez when these kids
decided to go look for some dead robots
I bet they didn't expect
as homeless teenage girl to help them or
to see a random mark Whalberg patrolling
the streets it's like this place is a
hotbed of X maka Tiffany they still
haven't fixed his fucking voice box hey
guys I'm having a problem
I want Cade to find the talisman somehow
how do I get it to him when he left it
with the dying transformer I know let's
have the talisman grow legs and be able
to walk on its own this mound of cocaine
isn't gonna snort itself I see the
transformer suddenly have the ability to
iron giant they're separated body parts
back together that is not awesome also
how did breaking himself apart then
pulling himself back together give him
any discernible advantage in taking out
a dozen puny humans oh do it big Merida
was this asshole the whole time was he
sitting in a Jeep watching all five
seasons of Las Vegas horribly my
invitation to this ass-kicking must've
got lost I don't know it just got lost
in the screenplay I'm pretty sure this
is page 14 but it got place where page
19 normally goes also Oh John Goodman
I've seen this franchise solely some
great actors John Turturro
Kelsey Grammer Stanley Tucci King
Anthony Hopkins but this one hurts the
most I think also bearded cigar-chomping
transformers let's discuss the evolution
of that either like tagging with
machinery as intricate as bumblebees how
does he not feel the tracker getting
shot onto his rear spoiler and even if
he couldn't feel it seems like he could
at least be able to be worn by something
I mean this is a transformer who can
tear himself apart and reanimate like
The Iron Giant for chrissake oh great
another goddamn artifact it's insane to
me that we've watched four movies and
not once did anybody bring this weapon
of ultimate power up
I am Quintessa the prime of life why is
Optimus so certain that the Transformers
God is responsible for the world dying
all she said was your world is dying and
I've been waiting for you and meet your
creator what she didn't say was all this
you see around you I did that in case
she confused it with England EU the
talisman has been bestowed you mean just
because the talisman which Kade refused
decided to walk into his car and he
picked it up that makes the talisman
work no one will be seated during the
crucial and exciting polo scene we
perpetuates a lie that's supremely
attractive women like Vivien are single
because of some sort of character flaw
why why do we tell ourselves these
stories Looby takes what I entered under
my breath while buying a ticket and
works it into the actual film dialogue
you
that's what people in America do they go
to Chinese websites to look at
Lamborghinis drop the cluesive right now
while mark wahlberg us is exasperated
mark wahlberg comedy routine i'm
wondering does cheap Sherman's cruiser
factor into this movie's plot at all or
is this movie just being a dick and
wasting time what's he doing here
notice how someone in the movie asks a
perfectly valid question and then the
movie creates a distraction to not
answer it seven signs of the Apocalypse
and that talisman showing up here is
numeral know isn't that great that they
created day trader basically tell cabe
what this talisman is and he doesn't
live in this junkyard so how does he
travel around without the TRF knowing
you're coming into your power now barely
transformers are born as babies slowly
grow up which is one of the stupidest
things Michael Bay has ever signed off
on and not saying something wait alien
robots are arriving on earth and numbers
to hide account sports stadiums are
smashed entire sections of major cities
are quarantined but they're still
fucking holding car races somewhere in
the world oh this has been yeah there
have been so many short cutaway scenes
in this movie causing loose threats I
could read it the hypothetical sweater
from Weezer's undone Ludi stops in China
for three seconds and then immediately
whiplashes you into Jordan is anthony
hopkins playing hannibal lecter again
because he looks like he's in a
completely different movie in this shot
I mean what a first name out of
Megatron's mouth for which of his crew
he once released from prison is this
little twerp I realize you want to
introduce new BOTS but Jesus I can't
make this up transformers is now
stealing a page from Suicide Squad
straight BOTS in for bank robbery
why is he in for being a Decepticon and
why would a Decepticon need to rob a
human bank
nitros Zeus hey guys you accidentally
put a Hasbro commercial in here I'm not
sure you guys knew that but I wanted to
tell you just in case oh you knew that
even worse I'll suck your brains
absolutely not yes No who did these
assholes think Megatron was going to
want in a deal like this the good
Decepticons
why the fuck are they even negotiating
rogue our asses bagging these
Decepticons now they let them out yeah
about that how in the ever-loving did
you bag these Decepticons yeah once
shown an arrest in these movies okay I'm
just gonna say it am I the only one
comfortable with how often BAE's camera
lingers on this teenage girl am i
projecting too much because that whole
made Megan Fox wash his car in a skimpy
outfit story Decepticons have just been
given Yeager's location and despite the
fact that we knew said location we are
just going to follow the Decepticons
there instead of getting in position
first and then giving them the location
[Music]
seems like this could have been done
without Megatron and his crew driving
down the road and giving away the fact
that they were coming for Cait when
there are a million entry points to the
junkyard that don't involve the use of a
fucking Highway kids man they are just
the worst also is this how Isabella
stayed alive so long openly challenging
Decepticons you can't tell me this
girl's street smart and then have her do
this so wait do you mean Cade set up
this trap in the middle of this ghost
town to blow up the Decepticons but the
explosion basically did nothing and now
they're on the run again so what's the
point
don't tell me he thought this would work
Cade knows his transformers transformers
five attack of the drones they're dead
any reason why this drone with a clear
shot misses Cade here other than pure he
was him the second drone which hasn't
fired any bullets goes to the comic book
movie school of fight tactics and it
starts rustling cake what are you doing
a minute ago you didn't even know what
these things were but now you're certain
they use facial recognition hello
monster Cade I have been sent to collect
you I decided to hide out in this random
elevator in this random building on the
off chance that you decided to run
inside guess my mom was wrong when she
told me I'd never cut it at the Miss
Cleo Institute really England UK you
don't say this is clearly the dumbest
location texts ever in that it tells us
not only redundant information but
manages to reduce this location to the
vague somewhere in a country
it gives us Sir Edmund has made quite
the journey in this movie going from the
UK to Africa back to the UK in little
under a day
cymbal look guys is this drone is going
to continue to be terrible at its job
can we just go on to the next scene
which is surely going to be the
long-awaited Mark Wahlberg acts with
Anthony Hopkins scene that we as the
human race have been begging for gah oh
good he lucked himself onto the
mothership drone they were just talking
about trying to destroy a guy what's
with the fake Threepio ripoff well I
guess if the movie admits the theft that
just goes away doesn't kill the
messenger well the messenger will kill
you wait what there will be no smack
service on this flight no drinks no fun
this is a flight from somewhere close to
Chicago to somewhere in England right
why wouldn't you give their passengers
something to eat or drink during this
trip especially if he's that important
tracking Jaeger he's over the pond right
now wait I thought you were tracking him
from that homing beacon on bumblebee is
this movie going to later reveal these
government assholes have a homing beacon
on Kate himself literally dissolve at
room temperature made from some old kind
of goat scrote him or something
I hope John Turturro was able to put
many of his descendants through Harvard
with that line has another name Unicron
Cybertron's ancient enemy it dates back
to at least 1986 wait you mean you're
not going to add great britain - how the
fuck are we supposed to know where we
are if you don't include that it's weird
before watching this movie I never once
got the urge to punch words you found a
man yet movie fails the Bechdel test so
hard that Wesley and university is going
to vacate Michael Bay's diploma is this
movie trying to be interstellar now Oh
No British Megan Fox is in a car that's
driving itself
movie asks us hey man this tank is
operated by Michael Bay just how he says
hello but you want to know don't you
dude
why they keep coming here I would have
removed a hundred sins from this movie
and an additional one thousand from the
franchise if Wahlberg just said
merchandising last surviving member of
the order of which you can't be serious
this goes on for some time but when a
movie is 150 minutes everything goes on
for some time
Burton gives his to kidnap victims a
history lesson in his own human lineage
first instead of just saying look robot
apocalypse soon here's how you help us
to watch the killed Hitler don't screw
with it that's the what that what I mean
chase read a history book Hitler died in
Argentina in 1962 and magneto killed him
amazing that Sam Witwicky was never told
this national treasure / Da Vinci Code
history of what Wiccans for three movies
movie suggests Frederick Douglass and
Harriet Tubman were part of this protect
the transformer society when I'm pretty
sure most of their energy was spent on
things way way more important than that
in fact five hundred sins for even
suggesting Douglass and Tubman were
concerned about goddamn Transformers
protect the secrets history of tongs
fullness you ever think Anthony Hopkins
looks back at his time at the Royal
Academy of Dramatic Art and thinks yep
this was all leading to Thor
transformers and red - I'm pretty
certain that the conspiracy to keep
transformers secret would not have
lasted centuries as this movie claims
especially if they help take down
fucking Nazis it all began in 484 ad
Jesus this history lesson is still going
around the campfire as a logical
explanation a logical explanation unlike
this weird cut between walking shots did
he pause for 150 steps or did you just
not care about matching with other also
I was around a campfire the other day
regaling a bunch of out-of-towners with
a story of Transformers one through five
and they couldn't come up with one
logical explanation as to why these
movies are twelve and a half hours
combined any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
Odyssey cloak impressive not really it's
a well-known phrase what would have been
really fun is if you asked him if he
knew where the quote originated before
blurting out the answer someone actually
convinced paramount that transformers
beating Saxon and Nazi ass would redeem
this franchise race Ivana
I look someone in the movie is providing
the soundtrack that's a joke I've never
seen before
there's no bid oh look someone in the
movie is providing a soundtrack
that's a joke I've never seen before it
cleaved to him by an alien race fused
with DNA so this staff made by an alien
race has a special I don't know Lansing
device that pricks fingers so you can
fuse it with your own DNA that sounds
made up and yes I know this is a movie
where everything is made up only a
direct descendant of Merlin himself can
weave this instrument of absolute power
if Vivian is the only person who can
find and use Merlin's staff why doesn't
the talisman immediately jump over to
her also honestly between the talisman
and the staff the wood weakens and all
the other pelant is officially broken
making you're saying that I'm related to
the wizard Merlin suddenly I feel like
I'm in an episode of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer as a sudden wisdom book is about
to prove all the doubters wrong and pave
the way for success what what the what
seems like a weapon that should make
this whole movies conflicts go away
Lexus Chevy well I pay a movie to
feature your car brand when every other
car brand is also going to be featured
why is this movie over 2.5 hours long
because of the essential tutor oh and
his transformer picker scene and of
course sir edmund tear is a page out of
his Transformers history book for
basically no reason it's just a picture
of what he already knows is happening
Jesus Christ counted a Transformers
movie 1 this British to boot managed to
turn into national treasure with robots
also if the earth which is actually
Unicron was preparing one day for a
battle with Cybertron why did it allow
Pangaea to break into a bunch of
continents remember this is a sentient
planet that wants to defend itself one
day but it lets its defense system
spread around the entire globe
if Vivian's dad knew that one day she'd
need to know where Merlin's staff was
located and he read stories to her like
a loving father why did he waste so much
time kicking her out of the office what
was the point of her dad being an
asshole to her all those years TRF in
this movie display omnipotence and
ineptitude in equal portions why'd you
pop the decoy car so far away why do you
call it a decoy car when you're
instantly spotted and followed in this
new red bull system PEZ missile
bumblebee is able to transform slightly
with unbelted passengers inside without
them flying out into the pavement it's
at this point I feel like any
sufficiently advanced ex machina is
indistinguishable from Harry Potter this
thing isn't gonna run who said it needed
to run the clue was Navy Museum it's got
to be with the staff is I thought the
staff would be the
nobody said anything about them needed
to use the submarine to get to yet
another ship assign their going to an
ancient ship that crashed hundreds of
years ago so how did this submarine that
was being used by the Navy museum
factored into the process for that long
and now this the greatest mission of
them all if this guy would stop
speechifying we could get out of here in
two hours or less guaranteed after the
TRF decided to hunt Kay down and kill
him they decided not to work with Josh
Duhamel anymore somewhere they decided
to work together again like nothing ever
happened
what happens in the alien ship stays in
the alien ship this character is
literally the opposite of entertaining
about Windows because I can see you this
sub has nine rear windows are those a
good thing seriously
this movie has time for a candlelit
dinner with the two leads in a submarine
by the way how the did they even get
candles if you assembled all the scenes
in this movie that were created
specifically to waste your time it would
comprise 75% of it oh my God look at
that it's a big alien ship which some
has never been discovered by anyone for
centuries not Jacque Cousteau Steve
Zissou
or James Cameron you're the last night
you figure it out why does he even need
to figure it out just before they
entered the ship Cade said the ship
knows we're here so why is the ship
being a dick now about where the staff
is I got the talisman motherfucker past
that oh oh look the transformer planet
is approaching the dark of the Moon oh
yeah I remember her she seemed really
important there for a while
come all this way for this character
speaking for the audience of son I had
Kate hasn't even looked at this coffin
for 10 seconds and he's already
declaring the trip of failure Kate 180
so hard that even the Exorcist demon
girl got whiplash watching this come the
discount grill Knight wants to know who
wants the staff but if the only people
who can access the ship are people who
by rule are allowed to use the staff
then who gives us maybe some of the
movies both pious both blah blah protect
the staff even though our rules say that
only a Wiccan can use it and now a clear
whip Wiccan has it let's waste more time
pretending we need an action scene black
remember zb7 you got to be that Autobot
again Marquis sins be after Optimus
Prime and then says he's always had my
back it's my turn to have his and I'm
just sitting here like are you gonna do
to help be defeat Optimus stupid Kade
hops on top of stupid Optimus and
stupidly doesn't die I hate you
and Bumblebee your oldest friend literal
voice ex machina I would lay down my
life for you and that's all it took to
snap Optimus out of his evil coma Jesus
his movie fucking hates anyone above a
fifth-grade reading level it's insulting
how insulting this movie is also I
thought bumblebees voice was gone
because he was missing his voice box and
earlier in the movie Steve Buscemi sold
him one that made his voice sound stupid
if you're telling me this is a
psychosomatic problem why did the
knockoff voice box work no look I've had
it this talisman sat here like an
asshole and waited to be useful purpose
of this thing has been unclear since it
first showed up here and there this
movie has given explanations for its
power but in the end it's a big old
crutch to get Mark Wahlberg a reason for
his paycheck also understand the Knights
revere the talisman but does that change
what evil optimists did
shouldn't he still be sentenced to death
chamber we gotta figure out what makes
it tick
ignition combustion fire is this the
stupidest line of dialogue in 2017 Sir
Edmund pulls out this special
transformer cane slash gun which does
virtually nothing except ensure that his
character is going to get blown the cup
in the next few minutes so these horns
emerge from the ground around Stonehenge
but I thought there were horns around
the world that used to surround
Stonehenge because everything was once
unified by Pangaea is this now an
entirely new set of homes also I thought
the horns on earth
aka Unicron were supposed to be used to
defend the planet not somehow used by
Decepticons to help an evil alien which
conquered hey let's take the 14 year old
girl were supposed to protect right to
the front lines you what was an Optimus
Prime already found because the meaning
of this I officially have no idea what's
going on now and the account of the ages
is etched into the cosmos shut up and
get to walk all under your butts here's
the standard michaelbay shots from
around the world climactic sequence it's
sure to be the same as the rest of them
they all messed up I see bumblebee has
his old pop culture reference voice back
probably gave the marketing department
the sigh relief
sigh the sauce brain literally just
flies right into a cliff of its own
accord everyone important survives this
I'm just gonna go ahead and add 500
sincere because I honestly don't know
what the these guys are shooting at
mostly worthless characters who somehow
found their way onto the TRF helicopter
will now prove their work they could
have made Isabela a badass like lower
from Logan but why do something awesome
like that glad the Tony Hale character
can act like a villain in the third act
of the film because after all what the
American people need right now is a man
of science being portrayed as a super
wronged super douchey asshole wow that
was easy
the bad guys decided to approach prime
using the useless fodder technique but
all this mechanical Bri you're showing
me I never understood it anyway if this
is like watching a movie through the
eyes of a Rorschach test it's like
playing mist but using a Castlevania
walkthrough to beat it now is something
so insanely useful not already won this
battle yet like couldn't have hit
Quintessa with that time stopping thing
do you the bullets actually do anything
to make it wrong is this like when
Superman fights Zod and they're punching
each other through buildings
[Music]
vivianne becomes a virtual baton in a
relay race so confusing it's practically
water polo why did he take the time to
transform into the truck he couldn't fly
at the heart of every legend there is
truth there are also terrible action
pieces the editing no character
development and incoherent story and
there is also the illusion of female
empowerment and body by two characters
who could have been way more awesome so
you can keep your truth dick we can't
understand it or appreciate it not again
oh yeah we bought a backup this time few
movie tries to shoehorn and end credits
scene about these horns that the movie
forgot earlier in order to get us
excited about a sequel and that sequel
is x-men apocalypse
anything that has a beginning has an end
meal I never looked back that and it
distracts from done now you are our last
hope
comments are not crazy Island
[Music]
I am what they say I'm a liar I'm a
charlatan
[Applause]
[Music]
what have I done what have I done what I
done